[Music]
let's go to Dallas Texas and talk to the
great and wonderful Dean Hey Brother
Dean what's
up not much Dr John how are you doing
today I'm all right brother what's up
man how can it
help well let's see the problem
statement would be this I don't have
anybody to talk to ah and talk to about
that what that really means is talk as
in stuff deep things uh venting on
somebody or something like that
so kind of puts me in a situation of
being pretty well isolated yeah do you
end up spending a lot of time online
trying to find common bonds
there no actually I don't good for you
man good for you um yeah I don't think
there's going to be a whole lot of
common bom
there um so have you always been kind of
a Lone Rangers this new that you found
yourself did you recently move like tell
me tell me the story how you came to
realize dude I got nobody well I left
home about 50 years ago uh all over the
world working living I live about half
my adult life been outside the country
uh I think I've had like 37 38 different
addresses in my life so yeah move around
you know how it is when you go into a uh
subdivision
lived there 5 six years you see all the
neighbors but you don't know any of
their names yeah
yeah um how old are you man 66 66 so why
now why have you thought man I need some
people well a little light bulb went off
one
day and uh uh my wife and I were having
a bit of a um a disagreement
and I got to thinking about it I
saidwell she's got her ladies group and
they all go Cy up and do their thing and
whatnot and I don't have anybody to go
talk to I think I need to do something
about that good for you man D you're
like a uh
modernday uh
hero I'm not I'm not kidding here's why
most 66 year old men who have a
disagreement with their wife and their
wife goes off to their friends to have
somebody they can just process it with
um they just sit in their
chair and they watch TV or they get on
some crazy conspiratorial website and go
down a rabbit hole or they go into the
garage and Tinker with something which
is nothing wrong with tinkering but man
recognizing dude I need somebody to talk
to so here's the
thing I've talked about this almost ad
nauseum I'm going to send you um two of
my books okay for free I'm just going to
hook you up with them if you'll read
them and there's some pretty extensive
stuff in both of them about both the
epidemic of loneliness it's just killing
us man from the inside out and some very
practical steps on what to do but I
usually distill it down into a couple of
things and I'll just ask you point blank
how weird are you willing to
get find
weird
um I have a neighbor I live out in the
woods and out in what they call in these
parts out in the holler
I thought it was like a road in a valley
but it's not it's a holler and she
literally got on a horse and went door
Todo cuz these places are all like
multiple acres and she held a big uh
cookout and told everybody to bring a
meal and we met by the side of the road
on a
creek and it was the funnest most
hilarious somebody brought a guitar
somebody brought their kids my kids are
running around all over the place um it
was a group of randos from multi multi
multi-millionaire attorneys to people
who' lived down in the holler for 50
years that had there were the retired
Farmers that had basically nothing I
mean it was amazing but it took one
person going door to door to door to
door to do that I've also heard of I'm
thinking back back to um during covid
when I had a neighbor come up and down
and said hey I'm doing a barbecue we're
all going to sit outside in lawn chairs
and the first one was kind of sparsely
attended he had me out there on some
tables had some chairs out there there
was four or five of us down there the
next one had like 70 people out there
cool and so I don't know if it's you
saying want to hang out and have coffee
and put a sign in your yard and you sit
out in the front yard and have a card
table out there and drink coffee until
somebody comes and you can read a book
um or you go to a local Starbucks and
buy somebody coffee or you go to your
local church and you say hey I want to
have a group of guys that just get
together and drink coffee on Tuesday
Mornings who's in and you're going to
have to know that it's just going to
take time over and over and over of
showing up and showing up and showing up
and finally somebody's going to go hey
man my wife's not all
right see what I'm saying yeah yeah but
I don't know a way of you finding
friends without a you going first and B
you being willing to um endure rejection
and just be weird and I say it's weird
it's not weird but in this modern world
to say hello to a stranger is is
somewhat weird pretty weird yeah yeah or
you instantly think what do you want are
you trying to sell me something
nope I bet you know what I bet if you
put a sign in your front yard that just
said lonely 66y old I've got great
coffee would love for you to hang out
and you put a car table in your driveway
I guarantee you I'd pull over and stop
and hang out with you I would call Kelly
and tell her I'm missing the show today
because I'm hanging out with my new
buddy
Dean I mean I here's the thing there's
any number of opportunities here I think
the big thing is you got to take action
on it it's not just going to it's not
going to heal itself yeah are you
connected with the local church
there um we go I don't spend a lot of
time there but
uh or a local Civic group or do you even
have a counselor that you can talk to
for a little while while you kind of
building this thing up that I don't have
okay and uh you know so that was one of
the things that I looked at is you know
maybe maybe go down that out and find
somebody to talk to you know but you
know 5 years or once a week is pretty
pricey I don't think insurance is going
to cover that n and I don't think I mean
from what you're telling me right here I
don't think you need five years in once
a week what a good counselor is going to
do is they're going to practice with you
the skill and art of conversation and
listening and being present with
somebody and those things are necessary
for someone to come tell you some deep
things or to listen when you tell them
deep things that you're experiencing
yeah right so I don't think you're going
to get stuck in a fiveyear loop by the
way you can always just walk away you
don't have to go but on the way to the
office today I had a someone who's a a
former colleague of mine who's in their
late 50s maybe early 60s who reached out
and I gave them the name of two
therapists I don't think that's weird at
all cool fact I just did that today to
somebody I care about so all that to say
um I think it's just going to take some
action by the way you're probably going
to need to learn some skills you've
moved a lot huh oh I've moved a lot yeah
you're a great acquaintance but probably
being a ride or die friend at 2: am is
Pretty Tough oh yeah absolutely okay
dude I'm proud of you man you give me
hope well thanks you give me hope man
but yeah um hang on the line here I'm
gonna hook you up with um both own your
past change your future and building a
non-anxious life and there's some pretty
clear directives on friendship and
building friends and the how we got to
where we got and what we do to walk out
of it but um at the end of the day it's
my friend Michael Easter he's like dude
I'm going to work out on on I'm going to
do my burn the ships workout once a week
if you're in Vegas you're welcome to
come um I'm trying to get better about
inviting people out with me hey I'm
going rucket if you want to come let's
do it I'd love for love to have you and
you my
friend whether it's front porch coffee
with Dean whether it's a sign in a local
Starbucks whether it is hey I'm going to
get a bunch of fajitas I'm going to
grill them out and I'm going to try to
do a neighborhood potluck and the first
one is going to be a bus so somebody
tell you it's not going to be great the
second one though might be awesome might
be great man meet your neighbors say
hello if you put a flyer I'm just going
to challenge you if you put a flyer on
the 10 houses to your right 10 houses to
your left across the street same 10 and
10 that's 40 houses and you said I'm
Grill and fajitas I'd love everybody to
come over for a potluck I'll have the
tables and you line up the tables on
your driveway invite everybody tell tell
everybody bring a dish and bring a lawn
chair bring your drinks or whatever man
you you're going to meet some neighbors
that could be fantastic what a cool cool
thing to do and everybody
listening we're entering into an
election year that's just what we
freaking need good God my goodness I
would
rather the list of things I would rather
do than enter into another election
season not pretty and probably not good
for radio um or for
podcast we need each other man we're
going to need it big time this year call
your neighbors set something up I'm
going to commit to doing it I hope you
will
too